we thought about you today Brady when we
saw that Aaron Rodgers was getting rid
of dairy he's not eating cheese Tom
Brady has a cookbook now what's going on
with today's NFL quarterbacks Oh Dan
first off thanks for having me on but I
think what you're seeing is look these
are two of the all-time greats right
there they're gonna be future Hall of
Famers at least in my opinion and I
would say that at this point you know
everyone's trying to find their little
advantage that they can and for a
quarterback
reducing inflammation in your body it's
pretty important because you know a lot
of times you're the one taking the hits
you aren't necessarily delivering them
so when you look at you know for example
a play like Cam Newton who I heard you
guys talking about earlier you know he
still has the ability to kind of deliver
hits when he at least he's running the
football so he's not really facing a big
of an impact as more your of your
prototypical pocket passes are so you
know the ability to ability to feel
better after a game even if it's the
smallest margin will make a difference
so you know cheese and those sorts of
things do create more inflammation in
the body so it can help you feel better
especially later on the season well when
those games matter the most did anybody
ever discourage you from getting too big
your arms too big oh yeah yeah actually
when I when I was come out in the draft
and Jon Gruden was the head coach at
Tampa you know he's famous for making
these videos right he's cut up videos
he's always going on TV with
quarterbacks for well we were sitting in
Charlie Weiss's office and he's going
through and he put up a picture of me
from the combine and and obviously you
know what my dad was a marine right so
he had me working out at a young age I
was I was eating total and product 19 I
found I was four so I worked hard so I
think it was part genetic part the fact
that I probably had a pretty decent diet
so I tend to look a little bit
muscle-bound in my photo and and he's
kind of looking at me going what are you
trying to do here man trying to get a
little more on your traps a little more
your biceps you think I want my
quarterbacks to look like this and then
you flip to a picture of JaMarcus
Russell from the combine his skivvies
you guys why don't you look like this
either
ironically enough
she put - a photo of Charlie fry who at
the time was a quarterback for the
Cleveland Browns I said it's the what
core I supposed to look like you know I
got like to go out have a beer with
because he does look more like this guy
and I again ironically enough line up
getting drafted by Cleveland and they
end up trading Charlie in the second
week that year so it's a little bit
weird but that was kind of the
perception I think a lot of head coaches
have especially a lot of the West Coast
offense style of coaches do you have to
be in great shape to be a great
quarterback as far as physical physique
I don't think that necessarily matters
that much I do think you have to be in
good cardiovascular shape because when
you have to scramble when you have to
run around or move in the pocket and do
the types of things you have to do and
then all of a sudden come back and call
playing huddle it can be difficult at
times so you've got to at least being a
good cardiovascular shape to go to come
back and spit the play out so you can
just say it once I mean if you have to
go over it again and again and again
because you're out of breath you're only
wasting time on the play clock what's on
the NFL training tables why do they put
bad food out there yeah there'll always
be some bad food I mean it depends on
where you're at certain days of the week
you know they'll have you know much of
fried food and things like that which
again isn't good for you it causes more
inflammation the body I mean I remember
when we're in Denver we went on that run
where we actually ended up winning me
the AFC West with with Tim and all that
we used to have these just ridiculously
greasy stinkers
every every Friday before we'd head out
on our away games or you know two years
ahead of time so that was our tradition
because once we started I think it was
called like Freddy Freddy steak burgers
and we were just pounding these triple
stack burgers just because we did it and
we started a streak and then everyone
Otto everyone was doing it
and our nutritionist just kind of kept
shaking his head but you had to keep
bringing it in because superstition
superseded and he sort of died that he
was going to put out in front of us at
that point do you think that Tebow was
was too in shape too jacked no not at
all I think a lot of people look at guys
who are more muscle-bound and they tend
to think that they're not as flexible
but that's where mobility comes into a
play I mean a lot of
quarterback's can still be muscle-bound
and still have the mobility to be able
to have a throwing motion and all that
that it's efficient as the proper
biomechanics I mean I just think for him
it was a mixture of not necessarily
developing I think mentally with some
things that are happening out in the
field and not really having enough time
to stir up his throwing motion it's
really hard to change the throwing
motion at that point in time in your
life in your career to really try to
tighten things up and make a huge change
he's Brady Quinn Fox college football
analyst also NFL on Fox analyst but let
me go back to Tebow how can you be one
of the greatest college quarterbacks of
all time but you can't throw the
football in the NFL well two completely
different games I mean the NFL is still
a pocket passing game I know we're
starting to see quarterbacks become more
mobile that's important because the
defense's are certainly become more and
more athletic and faster so the
quarterbacks have to you but if you if
you look at the way the game setup
especially the rules right in particular
pass interference where you get the
advantage of yardage that's opposed in
college where it's you know first down
and at first then you get to 15 yards
tacked on top of it so it's still a
pocket passing league to me and I adjust
in that case I think you're looking at
the style of offense you know the hash
marks are different so if you're making
completions into the boundary in college
it's a lot easier than throwing into the
boundary in the NFL because the hashes
are much more narrow it's a longer throw
and on top of it there's a running
element of things I think comes into
play that it's really hard to be able to
have a mobile quarterback in the NFL
last through 16 games throughout the
season because the hits are that much
that much more ferocious and it's just
harder to endure that that style of play
for that long time well I have you and
you cover college football and curious
what you think of what Jim Harbaugh is
doing here in the offseason tweakin
everybody yeah he's trying to take
advantage of every opportunity he can
get to try to get down in the south and
recruits over the town out there but I
think Nick Saban has brought us an
interesting points that this is kind of
a gray area with a lot of these
satellite camps and at this juncture I
mean there could be some things that
kind of maybe go under the radar that
could be recruiting violations
because this is something that's kind of
newer at least and I think we've seen
that maybe in the past few days but and
I think they'll figure out a way of
governing at all I think it allows high
school athletes more of an opportunity
to have a chance to go play for a school
like Michigan you know a big program up
north or otherwise they might not have
the exposure that these coaches are
necessarily able to come down it some of
these different satellite camps and meet
these kids face to face so I think it's
all in the best it should be all in the
best interest of the athlete at this
point and I think they just have to do a
better job to figure out how to govern
it would you rather play for Nick Saban
or Jim Harbaugh I don't know it's tough
I mean Nick Saban has the champion sis I
think you probably have to go in that
direction at least at this point but I
think you'd have much more fun with Jim
Harbaugh and but I guess looking at it
too and maybe I maybe I'll change my
mind because you know Harbaugh has got
more of the NFL pedigree at least from
when he was there in the success he had
and he was you know a former quarterback
got a lot of success as well so so maybe
he'd be able to see more eye to eye with
you as a player so as much as it pains
me to say cuz I really wouldn't want to
play for either you know I'm a Notre
Dame guy so but I'd have to maybe say
Harbaugh in this game
good to talk to you Brady as always
always fun back strap me on all right
Brady Quinn the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience
[Music]